katarina was testing her null hypothesis
is that the true population mean of some
data set is is equal to zero versus her
alternative hypothesis is that it's not
equal to zero and then she takes a
sample of six observations and then
using that sample her test statistic i
can never say that her test statistic
was t is equal to 2.75 assume that that
the conditions for inference were met
what is the approximate p value for
katarina's test so like always pause
this video and see if you can figure it
out
well i just always like to remind
ourselves what's going on here so
there's some population here she has a
null hypothesis that the mean is equal
to zero but the alternative is that it's
not equal to 0 she wants to test her
null hypothesis so she takes a sample
size or she takes a sample of size 6.
from that since we care about the the
population parameter we care about is
the population mean she would calculate
the sample mean in order to estimate
that and the sample standard deviation
and then from that we can calculate this
t value the t value is going to be equal
to the difference between her sample
mean and the assumed
the assumed population mean from the
null hypothesis that's what this little
sub-zero means it means it's the assumed
mean from the null hypothesis
divided by
our estimate of the standard deviation
of the sampling distribution i say
estimate because unlike when we're
dealing with proportions with
proportions we can actually calculate
the assumed based on the null hypothesis
sampling distribution standard deviation
but here we have to estimate it and so
it's going to be our sample standard
deviation divided by the square root of
n
now in this example they calculated all
of this for us they said hey this is
going to be equal to 2.75
and so we can just use that to figure
out our p value
but just let's just think about what
that is asking us to do so the null
hypothesis is that the mean is zero the
alternative is is that it is not equal
to zero so this is a situation where if
we're looking at the t distribution
right over here it's my quick drawing of
a t distribution
if this is the mean of our t
distribution what we care about is
things that are at least 2.75 above the
mean and at least 2.75 below the mean
because we care about things that are
different from the mean not just things
that are greater than the mean or less
than the mean so we would look at
we would say well what's the
probability of getting a t value that is
more 2.75 or more above the mean and
similarly what's the probability of
getting a t value that is 2.75 or less
below or 2.75 or mo more below the mean
so this is negative
2.75 right over there so what we have
here is a t table and a t table is a
little bit different than a z table
because there's
several things going on first of all you
have your degrees of freedom that's just
going to be your sample size minus one
so in this example our sample size is
six so six minus one is five and so we
are going to be
we are going to be in this row right
over here
and then what you wanna do is you wanna
look up your t value this is t
distribution critical value so we want
to look up 2.75 on this row
and we see 2.75 it's a little bit less
than that but that's the closest value
it's a good bit more than this right
over here but it's so it's a little bit
closer to this value than this value and
so
our tail probability remember this is
only giving us this probability right
over here our tail probability is going
to be between 0.025
and 0.02 and it's going to be closer
than to this one it's going to be
approximately this it'll actually be a
little bit greater because we're going
to go a little bit in that direction
because we are less than 2.757
and so we could say this is
approximately 0.02
well that's 0.02 approximately the t
distribution symmetric this is going to
be approximately 0.02
and so our p value which is going to be
the probability of getting a t value
that is at least
2.75 above the mean and or 2.75 below
the mean the p value p-value is going to
be approximately the sum of these areas
which is
0.04 and then of course katarina would
want to compare that to her significance
level that she said ahead of time and if
this is lower than that then she would
reject the null hypothesis and that
would suggest the alternative if this is
not lower than her significance level
well then she would not be able to
reject her null hypothesis